[Music]
100
believe her i do too me too but she's
not an american woman though she could
be a gold digging horn huh
good shot good shot
we'll see either or uh was shocked
when she discovered after 10 months
uh of her wedding that her husband was
not really a man but a female con artist
what oh flip the other one was a gold
digging [ __ ] dude holy [ __ ] well she's
still the golden horse she's not the
wife the the she husband can't believe i
believed her
the 22 year old said that she had met
her husband
online through a dating app where she
found out that he i'm gonna keep doing
this was a surgeon and a businessman
the couple secretly got married after
and the bride moved away from her family
the pan the pair moved to south sumatra
wait wait wait so she met
him in person and they lived together
they just so classmate anything what
point did she go
that's a [ __ ] she was strapped up
or maybe she was a she probably
microwaves the strap real quick yeah it
gets a little warm it's a warm nice and
hot shoots out fake piss if she needs to
says it's not you it's me they've always
had blindfolded sex is what happened
[Music]
that's the go-to yeah
she's like that she's like she's like
i've never had dick this good it never
stops getting hard just [ __ ] brings
it every time
and it just [ __ ] vibrates all the
time dude it's so strong could it fool
me i think sometimes it's removable damn
that's kind of weird because
geo only wants to have blindfolded sex
and then sometimes when we have sex it
feels like there's two penises in the
bed i don't know where that one came
from oh [ __ ] dude i think you're getting
strap attacked
i think someone's [ __ ] you in the ass
absolutely with [ __ ]
that's all you gotta check guys remember
when we were in the video we found out
bart was getting [ __ ] in the ass for
like ten years
[Laughter]
and we just glazed over and then we got
a streamy for it yeah
then we won the [ __ ]
i'm visualizing it bro yeah yeah i can't
wait till you get a stream we're gonna
win
i'm telling you we're going to win this
is our year finally reportedly the con
artist frequently annoyed the wife and
her family for money the wife said that
the man was unable to produce any legal
marriage documents or a penis or penis
the bride was confined to the house once
she got to know the truth about the
woman
and lady later her family tracked the
couple down
she took to social media to share her
story after her case got national
coverage she filed against her partner
in the zombie district court and her
parents reported the woman who pretended
to be a man to the authorities for
educational record fraud
she may face up to 10 years in prison
for her crime i want to see what that
disguise looked like yeah like i want to
know what i got to see a visual man
because i'm just so [ __ ]
you're just like
i like leave out a detail oh yeah she
was a blind bride yeah i forgot to say
that yeah
that could be you would do that they're
easy to con
what women right i'm not gonna say
anything else
damn i walked right into it dude
oh god wait what country is this in this
is it indonesia because like i wonder
what the what the laws are there for
like gay marriage and so i wonder if
they even like
like will accept the marriage is like a
legal thing now if they know that it's
like a fake like uh hopefully nothing
bad happens or if you could even get a
divorce you know some countries it's
like once you're married that's what i
mean is that like i feel like a lot of
these countries are so like strictly
like anti-like gay marriage that it's
like well they so what does the court do
at that point they're like oh we're
going to throw it out because the gay
marriage was like oh well i guess it'd
be yeah didn't they hang a dude in bali
before like being gained yeah yeah dude
so that's like also kind of scary
thought right there too huh because it's
a lesbian marriage yeah technically but
it's also like but one got duped so they
might have a little yeah but i'm
thinking that whoever's playing a man
right the husband one
is probably very passionate very what
passing like they're passing the [ __ ]
role maybe it's she's kind of trickiest
but she's a real door opener
you know what i mean so she's like oh
yeah that's a man for sure opening my
opening my door chivalrous yeah
especially those described
those big [ __ ] casino doors where
like no kid and woman can open that they
can't get it open
i saw two women like two grandmas trying
to [ __ ] go like that they're both
steve walked in the other door and was
like you guys figured it out i was like
why aren't you guys taking this the
other door was open
i walk up to the handicapped door and i
hit the button and you wait there is an
awkward like
and then you walk through yeah and if
there's a guy behind me in the
wheelchair like i was here first bro
he glides away put that thing in park
greatly underestimate the strength of
old people trying to get into a casino
they stop at nothing bro they will climb
the side of that [ __ ] wall you come
up through the sewer bro
through the manhole here's my favorite
slot i like the ones that still give
coins out dude nikki's grandma sits
there plays buffalo gold yo buffalo gold
i did not i did not have good luck at
that one bro she'll sit there it's like
you know whenever we get to vegas it's
like eight o'clock at night she plays
buffalo gold until eight the next night
bro she's sitting there the whole time
that's like the og gamers yeah i'm like
me and nikki went to bed i'm like i
[ __ ] her into a nightstand and then
like we go to the we go to the hospital
we come back like it's like four hours
later her grandma's still there playing
buffalo gold wow what a long cigarette
just just get almost
stacks of [ __ ] beer cans all over the
place cigarettes a pile of this hot
lines of cocaine just across the thing
yeah she's a coke user bro
coke user
my addict
lgbt rights was in question uh so i was
just looking that up just provide some
content how illegal because it is a very
muslim country obviously it's very
complicated um same-sex activity is not
illegal yet apparently but the legal
situation for lgbt people in indonesia
is getting worse
there is a strong movement apparently to
criminalize gay sex um
but i think so don't get married but you
can [ __ ] that's the that's no he said
it's crummy they're trying to
criminalize grace
you can right now right there yet i
believe get it in while you can can you
get gay married i don't think so because
of the muslim element but that's just a
populist thing so i guess if you're not
muslim and it's not illegal
how how did they get married fall in
love all this stuff
and not have any physical contact it's a
pretty conservative country i feel like
it's a lot of weight for you yeah i've i
would assume that there might be a lot
of random like situations like that
around the world you know what i mean
she met him online or him online and
there's also those situations right
where it's like people like uh are uh
betrothed to each other or there's like
arranged marriages and maybe in those
one it's like you might consummate for
the sake of like you need to have a
child but other than that you don't
necessarily like pen pal lovers have an
attraction or or love for that person
you know what i mean joe you you don't
think you could make someone fall in
love with you a thousand percent i can't
online for sure but then my dick will
get too hard and i can't resist joe had
some like indonesian man want to like
take care of him and have him cook for
him naked and stuff saudi arabia
that's pretty yeah how much how much a
week he said he said joe he goes i know
you're straight
but hear me out he goes i'm a big fan of
jk and i have an apartment here in saudi
arabia you can have it all i want to do
is cook for you in an apron and i know
you'd like doing the food vlogs and
stuff you're [ __ ] around
he wanted to cook for you in an apron
yeah nothing but apron so while he's on
the stove because he just wants me to
watch how beautiful he is it's like his
butt cheeks hanging out all this stuff
imagine watching this show
being like yeah
that one that is the one batman i have a
question out of all the guests how how
like you seriously got this inquiry
right yeah like did you actually
consider it at all like one percent nope
because when i get there
you know what's this is how they get you
because he's a guy you know he's gonna
make you buy the apron he's always gonna
[ __ ] try to test his limits yeah and
he's gonna turn around be like can i
suck your dick i'll be like come on man
that's not a part of the [ __ ] deal
yeah stay in the [ __ ] life don't
alter the terms so don't ask your
involved do this one time the best thing
about joe is he saw a uh he saw an email
and says i know your straight button he
goes
i want to wear a red apron he had
everything like described i was like wow
but i thought it was like i gotta know
you sent a picture he was like no i
didn't ask i should have asked right
damn can i get an example you know
yeah just the best thing so i think he
really was picturing this [ __ ]
fantasy of being in front of a stove
right nothing but a red apron [ __ ]
cooking my favorite dish being a good
housewife turning around and i'm like
you know what if i was gay
that is a very [ __ ] dope pickup line
that's like that that's very like
like not only nurturing and loving and
accommodating that's like it's all about
me and i was like dude that's that's
very cool
too bad i don't like dick
you know
if i like dick
in a man's butt that would have been a
wonderful
wonderful you do like blow jobs i do but
not from a man but what if a blindfolded
[ __ ] you wouldn't even know all right
that's true but then i'd have to go all
the way to saudi arabia for that
and lord knows if i'm gonna get stuck
there or not i don't know what breakfast
would you ask him to make for you that's
my that's like my burning question yeah
i mean sometimes i feel pancakes
sometimes i want belgian waffles but
like it just depends i'll be like can i
get the [ __ ] ube pancakes today he
goes i'm saudi arabian i'm like learn
how to make it dog
figure it out
nina actually just got
an igdm and she texted me this yesterday
uh and it says hello pretty can you be
my texting buddy smiley emoji i will be
paying you weekly allowances of 800
twice in a week to help yourself
financially dude just for a text buddy i
was like [ __ ] do it
what did she say she gonna do it she
joked around about it but obviously
she's not gonna do it just a texting
buddy some people just wants to talk
it's a pen pal just do it for like a
month because dude this is what joe said
bro right guys you're going to push the
boundaries
every time not just text it's going to
turn into sext oh no i'm just your
friend just because you're super hot
chick i just want to be your buddy at
all yeah dude totally because i know
it's going to start off with an
apartment and then it's going to start
and it's going to be like i'll suck your
dick but i'll give you a mansion and i'm
like i'm not going to say no to that so
i have to keep boundaries for myself
my own boundaries you have to have
defenses for yourself yes and then he's
going to be like oh i finished the
dinner can i eat like we're going to
probably [ __ ] sit there eat breakfast
he's naked in the apron and then he's
gonna be bored and he's gonna be like
how about
i bend over and pick up a fork for you
and you can see my [ __ ] and i'm like
why would he say that
part about it is that he finds himself
so alluring that he can just stand there
in an apron and you'll he'll you'll be
just irresistible
we don't know what he looks like he
might look amazing yeah he might look
great that's why i said but he didn't
get a picture he might also just be some
fat dude in april yeah you might be it's
a win-win really
might be just [ __ ] nadine dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you